et voilà donc on va retrouver quand même
j'ai donné cinq minutes on va faire une
interview déjà donné
alors elie semoun vous êtes dieudonné
oui j'ai suivi ça va du dos bah je
dirait 'nul les personnes de couleur
on n'a pas joué non merci je vais pas me
lancer là dedans ce que je vais avoir un
procès dont elle suit dieudonné donc
j'aurai habitués à voir des procès je
suis vieux de dieu d'accord je donnais
ceci vous fait bizarre vous voir sans la
barbe à la télé ouais mais j'ai fait ça
parce que
actuellement je suis sur un tournage de
film donc c'est pour ça que
10 on essaye de ressembler le plus
possible mon ancien collègue
elie semoun c'est pour ça donc je dois
interpréter le rôle d'un juif c'est pour
ça c'est parfait si non c'est pas
évident ce n'est pas évident pour vous
je me suis entraîné chez disons qu'on a
jeté des pièces de monnaie puis je me
suis jeté dessus donc ses portes elle
dieudo vous avez écouté l'album solo
d'elie semoun a long way le rossignol le
rossignol chantant j'ai écouté ça non
mais c'est bien il a raison de faire ça
parce que disons semaine agitée à un
petit plus à sa carrière quoi si je peux
lui donner un coup de pouce
éventuellement le pousser dans un
précipice
il a fini par nous vous connaissez
kevina cabinet deminor contente de cela
est-ce que vous accusez le public d'une
à ben non c'est à dire qu'en ce moment
ça devenir une fan je compte mes poils
de la visière carrière solo qui est dit
ce témoin niveau de la carrière 10 on
élit après pris une tangente qui ne me
ressemble pas circuler librement dans le
commercial
il fait des gros sel il vend énormément
des cassettes alors que moi j'ai préféré
faire ça le contraire est ce que quand
même c'est pas vrai j'exagère parce que
j'ai fait le zénith ya pas longtemps il
y avait du monde
d'ailleurs il ya mon copain guy bedos
qui est monté sur scène et qui a un
petit peu insulté sur scène devant les
gens qu'est ce qui va de l'autre il a
dit il est rentré sur scène il a dit
enfin bon moi je suis pas responsable il
a dit wen est pas là et c'est mango nos
idées en train de chanter
pis là il ya quelqu'un qui a violé dans
le public et puis il a dû roi du nom
d'un droit de se moquer des juifs sans
être antisémite s'est donc dit bono se
sait c'est mon ami divya lui répond la
bon maintenant que les réconcilier
dieudonné voulu passer des coups de fil
de temps en temps et sur sa page il est
appelé pour son anniversaire
je les appelais quand sa famille est
décédé on s'appelle non mais on s'aime
beaucoup hein y'a pas de soucis alors
dieudo à des petites vannes comme ça
mais c'est c'est l'amitié haine l'amour
haine un message avait pensé à faire un
duo un truc un peu de sketchs ou non un
exemple sinon je le sens pas je vais
peut-être me mettre avec un chinois
chose dieudo c'est vrai que je vais
faire une tournée en israël pour votre
prochain spectacle
je vais prendre un mais je vais y aller
en casque avec un casque est ce que
lourd au fait vous avez un petit mot à
dire à elie au câble perdre l émission
joe donnelly
si tu regarde l'émission tu le sais
que je t'aime bon bah c'est sûr on a eu
des rapports un petit peu conflictuelle
mais tu le sais toi et moi c'est pour
toujours
rien eu
et maintenant tu as i phone du boss
bon choix en france
bonsoir temps
non
ban
alors j'ai tous les deux à nouveau
réunis dans pour les fameuses petites
annonces sixième volume
elie semoun annonce la suite avec vous
deux alors il ya un casting absolument
incroyable de guest-stars ya arthur il
ya adriana karembeu axelle laffont des
dany boon bernard montiel laurent voulzy
lorànt deutsch estelle lefébure et
julien clerc et on est loin des les
blondes à forte poitrine en main
d'oeuvre non mais c'est vrai il ya un
casting du diable ah non valériane mieux
bien sûr tout nous dire oui 1
mais surtout nous deux oui c'est comme
jacques chirac toi je suis apte enrayer
la période je me suis agenouillé lui la
bernadette bois ju catherine barba
cicatrice est bon bien donc un casting
du diable sur ce truc
ouais ouais mais dans les autres casse
est aussi en plein de gens 1 seule fois
ya un paquet de gens qui veulent tourner
avec nous c'est parce que c'est on se
marre bien sûr rigolo de se déguiser
c'est vrai que tous les copains ou non
toujours moi quand est ce que je fais un
truc c'est marrant de venir mettre une
moustache ou ou une perruque on est tous
des gamins qui viennent une robe maman
bien sûr bien sûr marié tôt je suis jean
flanc g45 années et je réside dans le
val de marne françois pagnes tissés à
ba2 nous sommes
françois nous sommes réunis par le même
handicap qui font soit sûrs tu t'es
endormi bonjour je suis jean flanc nous
sommes réunis par le même handicap
l'endormi site aiguë qui peut aussi
provoquer des troubles de mémoire
françois qui est endormi non par ghost
of pardon c'est jean-pierre j'avais
oublié à la voyez c'est terrible on
vous pouvez nous aider à combattre ce
terrible fléau en envoyant en retard je
m'étais pas réveillée
bonjour je suis jacques vignaud vous
pouvez envoyer vos dons à cette adresse
1 grenoble bonjour merci au revoir au
revoir
le premier apparemment bonjour donc
j'essuie jacques vignaud bonjour je
m'appelle marcus et j'ai douze ans c'est
pas grave merci bonjour je m'appelle
gilles je suis mi homme mi femme s'est
pas dad
bonjour je m'appelle cécile suis ma
femme me grizzly ça non plus c'est pas
grave bonjour je suis c'est pas grave au
log diplômé de ça va s'arranger
théologie je pratique que cette
philosophie qui fait que dans quelques
situations qu'elle se soit bien bonjour
je suis bernard montiel
non non je peux rien faire
si quest se moquer d'une personne parce
qu'elle est attirée sexuellement par new
wave j'aime les hommes elle est bonne
celle ouais j'ai eu un coup d'oeil dire
écochèques mon doudou est bon ce pays
câlins sous la couette oms neige ou
roméo et juliette
on range ses tabous de mer dont ceux
présents ou dans un pack à sopalski
foutu je suis peiné mais je suis pas une
gonzesse l'accord à moi je suis motard
quand il faut changer les 4 ou de la
kawa bas je remonterai les les trousses
d'un mât chemisette et puis je me fous
les mains dans le cambouis j ai le
premier quelque chose à dire il le
rappeur hamé gif bonjour vous désirez
briller en société au bras des plus
grandes stars des frontières actuelles
et bien c'est possible grâce à nos gens
seront meilleures chances de sosies de
stars
d'autres sociétés vont très bien on
commence la présentation chéri que c'est
qu'il veut bien dans un bon jour je suis
marie-christine adriana karembeu je te
présenter sa d'ibiza
bonjour julien vitesse et la première
chaîne
bonsoir et je me perds tu vois tu sais
c'est pas beau tout ça à l'infini
c'était possible présence de tous donc
une petite fille ou une jupe taille
haute
on dirait une chef bonjour je m'appelle
laurent voulu cela ça ça c'est bien
sympathique les gens sautaient le
contingent sur des sosies de stars
encore tva sociale mais il est où notre
jean croissance nationale 1
excusez moi j'étais au gala mont pelé
ouais là je n'étais pas le radeau de la
méduse le bateau scènes mythiques et
vina unis quand vous devez bien
connaître aux fans de tunisair ont la
triste remis nam trop sympa un plus ça
s'appelle que ma petite soeur louise
virginie ouais jennifer née telle est
son concept qui ont acheté un anneau
soussen nom n'a pas envoyé seul mois tu
l'a pas reçue en me désole
alors autant ne rien par la poste
on voulait savoir s'il voulait pas
parler de noël son émission en plus ce
serait trop bien qu'ils viennent à la
niche de damien s'afficherait très bien
que sa copine démenti raisin yaya qui va
les filles comme entité paix elie
annoncé moon la suite
bon quand on voit les réactions
publiques ici on passe de commentaires
qu est-ce qu il yal dérivés il ya une
mère de malus en plus chaque fois dans
ce malus dans ce malus y est j'y voyais
le bêtisier yvan nom marrant il ya et
puis il ya toute la phase ii d'écriture
de préparation enfin tous les invités
qui viennent et c'est ça a été vachement
bien monter c'est le favori qui a fait
scénarisé c'est drôle ce qui se passe
dans le délai vers en ce moment parce
que par exemple sur ton sur ton dvd là
des je vous ai pas raconté au zénith
il ya un truc où on entend en hantant
les techniciens qui parlant être laissés
ouverts les micros les techniciens et on
voit comment les mecs qui balance sur
toi pendant ton spectacle de ma gueule
et ils me l'ont dit pendant toute la
tournée on soupe sa gueule tous les
soirs pendant que tu joues pas parce
qu'ils ont eu d un psychiatre comme on
les assistants ici ils se parlent entre
eux et mondiaux fait l'enregistrement va
te montrer j'ai trouvé ça vachement
drôle et j'ai mis dans le dvd dans le
bonus c'est assez créatifs les dvd
lensois tout ce qu'on fout sur un dvd en
plus du spectacle parce que les gens
sont de plus en plus exigeants il faut
il faut un beau truc là comme on appelle
ça c'est le machin télévision non elle
et moi
comment rester sinon qu'on appelle ça
les coques cotisable sur un petit truc
j'étais plus si on découvrait recommande
d'ailleurs battu mais ce dvd
tu vois tu as un menu mois ci nous
battre et cela l'avait dit avant serge
petit replay en faire je vais plus
la commande des menus derrière non mais
du froid est maintenant c'est les
banques ont maintenant c'est le
cimetière monde et chacun pour sa gueule
alors dans dans ce dvd de je vais pas
raconter au zénith
il ya des rappels un temps là que les
gens comprennent là on parle pas du
disque en parle pas des petites annonces
on parle du délai seront d'accord c'est
drôle ce qui se passe dans le dvd en ce
moment parce que par exemple sur ton
spectacle sur le dvd de son spectacle au
zénith je vous ai pas raconté il ya un
moment tu laisses les pistes des
techniciens ouvert non alors ouais
attend ouais mais aussi la leur et ceci
durant vingt six bambins je me rappelle
que je suis un peu surpris que vous me
posiez cette question là c'est marrant
c'est que dvd en ce moment j'ai un peu
pris au dépourvu que je suis là mais
voilà ça
attendez quelle prise vous voulez qu'on
prenne au montage la roya ou la deuxième
tout tout tout d'accord avec ces public
qui décide du montage donc pour mon
disent que c'est vrai que les gens
n'étaient pas d'accord au départ et que
je l'attends non il est plus facile pour
un chameau
ah oui le temps le chas d'une aiguille
que pour un riche d'entrer royaume des
cieux caisse cas sur votre bonus à vous
ni à des scènes coupées
ouais pas mal le prochain spectacle
c'est septembre 2004 au bataclan au
bataclan
elle vous savez déjà vous allez jouer
oui je sais même après où j'ai joué et
élevé dans le mgc même en 2006 petit
calcul et pendant combien d'années je
sais que oui on en 2008 2005 je connais
le jour où cela merlot à voir ce que je
préfère en 2006 tu pourrais toi non mais
même si tu es écrasé dans la rue les
jours après pour le planning c'est fou
tout le monde dans la merde quoi non
mais ça se réserve une salle pour le
bataclan 100 jours sont situées en 2006
toi pas du tout même
mais tu m'étonnes toi bah ouais on est
d'abord un bon 2005 déjà jusqu'à fin
2016 bon farmer quand tu dis comme si
c'est la micro-société marmara toujours
là mais écoute dans 15 ans je sais
attends tu sais pas ce que tu vas faire
dans 15 ans si je sais ce qu à biline
attendu c'est après le spectacle mon
petit chéri
enfin non mais je sais on quand on joue
un spectacle on sait qu'on va faire une
tournée après alors après ski entre les
deux jours c'est donc le spectacle est
pas écrit mais tu sais déjà que tu vas
le faire au bataclan et tu fais la suite
celui-ci les pratiques arriverai il
rentrait dans le bonus du prochain dvd
alors non le bonus du prochain dvd en
vigiles attaquent lent il y aura le
prochain spectacle d'après